Você acorda cansado mesmo depois de
dormir 8 horas. Sua pele está inflamada
sem motivo aparente. Os exames voltam
normais, mas você sabe que algo está
errado. E se eu te dissesse que existe
uma toxina microscópica que pode estar
vazando o seu intestino pra corrente
sanguínea todos os dias, acionando o seu
sistema imunológico como se fosse uma
invasão constante. Uma revisão publicada
no Internal and Emergency Medicine com
mais de 660 citações científicas
confirma essa condição chamada Lakigut
está conectada à obesidade, doenças
autoimunes, neurodegeneração e fadiga
crônica. E a medicina ortodoxa raramente
investiga isso.
Deixa eu explicar o que está acontecendo
dentro de você. No seu intestino vivem
trilhões e trilhões de bactérias. As
granegativas, que são a maioria, tem na
sua parede externa uma molécula chamada
lipopolisacarídeo
ou LPS. Quando a barreira intestinal
está íntegra, esse LPS fica onde deveria
estar dentro do intestino. O problema
começa quando essa barreira se rompe. E
o que causa esse rompimento? O dia tá
rica em gordura, gordura ruim, tá?
Gordura artificial também, rica em
açúcar, estresse crônico, uso excessivo
de antiinflamatórios. álcool, disbiose
intestinal. Quando a barreira falha, o
LPS atravessa paraa circulação e aí
começa o caos. O LPS é reconhecido pelo
sistema imunológico através de um
receptor chamado TLR4.
Quando esse receptor é ativado, ele
dispara uma cascata inflamatória brutal.
TNF alfa, entele 6, intelecina 1 beta,
seu corpo entra em modo de defesa como
se estivesse sendo atacado por uma
infecção. Só que não existe infecção, é
uma guerra contra fantasmas. E essa
guerra consome energia, inflama tecidos,
desregula hormônios. Um estudo publicado
no Neuro Endocrinology Letters pelo
pesquisador Michomeas
mostrou que a normalização do intestino
impermeável ou hiperpermeável em
pacientes com síndrome da fadiga crônica
foi acompanhada de melhora clínica
significativa, ou seja, conserte o seu
intestino, melhore da fadiga. Agora vem
a parte que a medicina ortodoxa ignora
completamente. Quando você chega no
consultório com fadiga crônica, dor
difusa, pele inflamada, o que que
acontece? Hemograma, TSH, glicemia, vem
tudo normal, né? Você recebe um
diagnóstico vago, talvez fibromialgia,
talvez estresse, talvez depressão e sai
com uma receita de antidepressivo ou
relaxante muscular. Ninguém investiga
permeabilidade intestinal, ninguém mede
zonulina, ninguém questiona se existe
endotoxemia de baixo grau, destruindo
você de maneira silenciosa. Então, uma
pesquisa publicada no Enels of the Real
Matic Diseas em 2023, estudou pacientes
com lupos eritematos sistêmico, uma
doença autoimune. Controu exatamente
isso. Maior permeabilidade intestinal
medida pelo teste de lactulose manitol,
níveis elevados de zonulina e SCD14
e resposta aumentada ao TLR4 indicando o
quê? Endotoxicemia.
A disbiose intestinal e intestino
permeável estão contribuindo ativamente
paraa patogênese da doença autoimune.
Não é consequência, é causa. E sabe o
que que piora tudo? A dieta ocidental,
um estudo do International Journal of
Vitamin and Nutritional Research de
2023, detalhou como monossacarídeos,
gorduras ruins, glúten, sal, álcool e
aditivos alimentares afetam as junções
entre as células intestinais, aumentando
a hipermeabilidade.
Esses componentes também causam disbiose
que por sua vez aumenta ainda mais a
permeabilidade de um ciclo vicioso que
se retroalimenta. Mas existe esperança.
Um estudo publicado no Scientific
Reports em 2023 mostrou que uma dieta
rica em fibras sementáveis,
especificamente pectina, reduziu
significativamente a severidade da UVIT
autoimune, ou seja, uma inflamação
dentro do olho interno em modelo
experimental. E qual que seria o
mecanismo? Aumento de células
Tregulatórias, supressão de linfócito
TH1 e TH17
e crucialmente redução da permeabilidade
intestinal. Outro estudo no Journal of
Nutritional Biochemistry demonstrou que
probióticos compostos aliviaram hepatite
autoimune em modelo animal através de
modulação da microbiota, manutenção da
integridade da barreira intestinal e
bloqueio da translocação de LPS. Então,
o que que você pode fazer? Primeiro,
elimine os gatilhos. Açúcar refinado,
óleos vegetais processados, álcool,
alimentos ultraprocessados. Segundo,
alimente a sua barreira intestinal.
Fibras fermentáveis como pectina,
presente em maçãs e frutas cítricas,
vegetais ricos em polifenóis, alimentos
fermentados. Terceiro, considere
suplementação estratégica, glutamina
para nutrir os enterócitos, zincarnosina
para reparar mucosa, probióticos de
qualidade para reequilibrar a
microbiota. Quarto, e isso é
fundamental, reduza, por favor, reduza o
seu estresse. O eixo intestino cérebro é
real e o estresse crônico aumenta
diretamente a permeabilidade intestinal
via liberação de cortisol e alteração do
sistema nervoso entérico. A verdade é
que seu intestino é muito mais do que um
tubo digestivo. Ele é uma barreira
imunológica, um órgão endócrino, um
segundo cérebro. Quando essa barreira
falha, as consequências reverberam por
todo o organismo. Fadiga que não passa,
inflamação que não cede, autoimunidade
que progride. A medicina ortodoxa
convencional vai continuar tratando
sintomas enquanto ignorar a raiz, mas
você agora sabe onde procurar. Se você
tem fadiga crônica inexplicada, as
doenças autoimunes, inflamação
persistente, investigue seu intestino,
peça exames de permeabilidade
intestinal. a zonulina, o LPS binding
protein. Questione, não aceite o rótulo
de que é psicológico quando existe uma
explicação biológica que pode ser
investigada e tratada a fundo. Seu corpo
está tentando te contar algo, aprenda a
ouvir. E para fechar, uma verdade
incômoda. O YouTube e o próprio ambiente
regulatório me obrigam a simplificar
muita coisa aqui. Eu preciso cortar
detalhes de dose, suavizar protocolos
mais avançados e evitar combinações of
label que na prática clínica fazem
diferença real. Então, dentro da
comunidade fechada, eu não preciso
colocar esse filtro. Lá eu compartilho
exatamente os protocolos que eu uso em
consultório, casos de reversão que
pareciam impossíveis se eu contasse
insoltos, combinações avançadas e
fornecedores confiáveis, além de
interpretação fina de exames e
atualizações de artigos linha por linha.
é praticamente ter acesso direto ao meu
raciocínio clínico. Temos dois níveis
nesse nosso grupo. Temos lives semanais,
materiais em PDF com dezenas de
protocolos e grupo exclusivo no
WhatsApp. Você deixa de ser um
espectador passivo e passa a fazer parte
do ciclo interno que está realmente
comprometido em dominar a medicina
funcional aplicada com profundidade, sem
superficialidade de rede social. Se isso
faz sentido para você, o botão seja
membro está aqui embaixo. Poucos têm
coragem de dar esse passo. A pergunta é:
você está entre esses poucos?